[Music]
yo yo
listener this is the plastic pills
podcast uh you have clicked on either on
purpose or accidentally
our idea look on
super episode
super
super super big one
which you get which you can probably
tell from the length
i'm not sure it's probably it's probably
i hope it's not three hours it's
somewhere around there anyway we smashed
two episodes together on adir lakan
which is something you know all of us
have to say maybe at some point or
another you you read de las and guitaree
you get too dependent on analysis
because you just love hearing yourself
speak and filling space
maybe it's time to idea look on and get
a hobby but no
today
adila khan bye to our boy is the title
of a film so it is a film episode
which is in two parts so brace
yourselves first we watched it
we kind of mold over our thoughts and uh
questions it's kind of like a review
not just of the film but review in the
sense of reviewing what what
psychoanalysis and lecon are about a
little more generally so you can get
caught up yeah yeah yeah and then the
second half we actually got the director
of the film and writer actually writer
director of the film to come on and
answer some of those questions that we
had about his depiction of lacan on the
silver screen the only depiction i've
actually seen of the khan on the silver
screen
so it's one of the few that's the first
director we've talked to i believe oh
yeah we've definitely never i think i
would have remembered talking to another
director
outside of our comfort zone but inside
of our intellectual curiosity yeah so if
you're looking at the length of this
episode i'm not sure whether you want to
commit
i think you do
we matched what could have been two
episodes into one here so i don't know
how you listen to podcasts if you're
driving make sure it's a long drive if
you're at the business factory
make sure you don't have to pause it for
your boss and if you're trying to put on
something boring while you fall asleep
well [ __ ] you
well if you're curious about what a
psychoanalytic
treatment session set of sessions
what a psychoanalytic treatment regime
looks like this film actually fills in
this complete almost lack of
any kind of representations of the
psychoanalysis process the clinical
psychoanalysis process that lacan
and others would have been involved in
so this is an awesome film it fills in a
gap
actually i mean what if you were like
the sopranos right you saw that
depiction well this one is even more
realistic
and there's a lot there there's a lot of
depth there's easter eggs of all sorts
not only of french statues and things
but also of lacanian ideas if you're
familiar with lacan a little bit you
might spot a few things in there it's
really a uh
it's really a smorgasbord i think yeah
links in the show notes if you want to
watch it before listening to this but it
was the source material on which the
film is based was written by an actual
analyzand of lacon
so there's some degree of accuracy here
yeah betty milan fictionalized her
experience of
psychoanalysis and this film is based on
that which which ironically makes it
feel very realistic and very very um
yeah true to
what a lacanian psychotherapist would
do right and although it is not a
hundred percent spoiler-free we don't
really give too much away and i guess
it's not even really the type of film
we're giving away plot has much effect
on the experience anyway
it's true i was actually thinking about
that because the director himself
ended up um
like kind of letting slip a bunch of
spoilers that i think in our review we
made like a concerted effort to not talk
about like i think maybe like one or two
things
and then as he was saying that i kind of
did realize i thought to myself i was
like well it's true this is the kind of
film that like you're not really waiting
exactly
it's about like
watching this process unfold in front of
you and like whether you i can't imagine
like whether you know certain things
happen or not it will make much of a
difference to your enjoyment of the film
so yeah if you see a lineup of people
waiting to go see this film in a theater
or something shouting out the ending is
not going to ruin it like it would
authorize something like that right and
if you do see a lineup of people waiting
to see this film you should probably go
hang out with them because i
they're probably cool
yeah if they're interested in lacon
which
i have been and the research i did for
this episode kind of brought that back
so it's not that's nice
so without further adieu
[Applause]
okay why didn't why did the unconscious
do that without further ado that wasn't
in your script no i was reading the word
idea when i said that which is why it
came out without further ado
because it's the title on my
uh
point for him here is us from two weeks
ago oh yeah this is the one other thing
we recorded it two weeks ago so i used a
[ __ ] mic
instead of this mic so forgive me that
i'm a perfectionist when it comes to my
mics
couldn't use my good one anyway bad mike
then good mike us again from two weeks
after we recorded the first one
joined by richard leeds the writer
director of adida
khan
so we hope you enjoy this uh entry into
the fantasy world of cinema
and thank you very much for listening
and without much more idea about nothing
well the face to face is over
sarayema no longer needs to look at me
she can lie down and listen to herself
it's a victory
people live their lives without
listening to themselves
with a tin ear
some even die without ever listening to
themselves
eternally deaf to their own speech
to their own body
which screams rather than talks
a deafness that in itself is enough to
justify psychoanalysis
if it still needs to be justified
all right listeners we are
in different time zones and pills is
without his regular recording equipment
so if it sounds a little funky
forgive me but yeah i'm recording on
vacation because that's how important it
is yeah you just sound further away
you do sound further away
[Laughter]
i'm not i'm right here boys
west coast
yeah it is anyway we got a we got a
double header i think we're probably
going to mash these two episodes
together and if that doesn't end up
working out then you'll never hear this
audio anyway
cut cut cut yeah yeah we'll have to find
out how to pronounce uh his last name
eric did you find out
no that interview was in french and it
was just a snippet i have to do more
research so we'll say richard leeds or
richard lettuce
yeah just cut around the right one but
we as we know from the film as well your
identity is not in what you call
yourself in any way
it's in what you do not call yourself
true
so if you're wondering what we're
talking about we watched an indie film
i could say a very indie film
called uh adir lakhong yeah and it stars
uh david patrick kelly as jacques lacon
who is like
a fairly well like well-known or he's
kind of one of those actors that like
you wouldn't know him by name but if you
saw him you might recognize him because
he's been in like a bunch of stuff i
think
he was in um from the same i always
forget the name for some reason because
i wasn't like that big of a fan of it
it's the same director as maul hall and
drive that showed that like he had to
come back twin twin peaks right yeah
yeah twin peaks so he was in he was in
that and a few other things spinning
gossip girl
was he was some other stuff maybe
apparently maybe that it could just be a
couple
shows i don't know if it was a whole
season or the whole show
could have been just a cameo he
definitely resembles lacan as well he
does
he had a convincing
french intellectual aesthetic if that
makes sense
even though the movie was in english
lacanian gestalt for sure
chomping on the cigar always helps with
the french aesthetic exactly exactly
anyway we're not gonna do anything like
a regular film review which is
what do you think about the acting what
did you think about the blocking because
none of us know [ __ ] about that and we
have no problem admitting it so maybe we
have opinions but those are probably not
the ones that we're going to spend too
much time on yeah we do have all
opinions on lacan however oh i just have
to drop in one more thing that david
patrick kelly is in
probably a role people may be familiar
with if you've seen a little movie from
the 70s called the warriors
uh it's this dystopian movie about all
these gangs in new york
and he plays the guy that that delivers
that famous line you know warriors
come out and play
that was him that's david [ __ ]
patrick kelly he plays uh he plays uh
uh what's the character's name yeah
luther and the warriors yeah
the crazy guy who that's so funny
apparently according to
main characters according to wikipedia
that might have been his first ever film
role which is pretty cool so that puts
that i now i recognize him totally from
hearing about that role
so that puts i mean so you can see he's
you know he's an actor who's been uh you
know who who's been in the business for
a long time can say um but i will also
say like i know we're going to talk
about lacan i mean i did enjoy the film
uh
you know i don't know if that's just
because i'm interested in lacanian
theory right i can't say whether or not
people who don't know about lacanian
theory will
find it interesting but i i liked it uh
for that reason alone because it's
pretty rare to find a film that actually
like focuses on you know a pr well in
this case it's really the his
practitioner side
uh his analyst side
not necessarily his theoretical side but
still you know for for me someone
who influenced uh the way i think about
uh the world and people so to see a film
that
sort of uh depicts uh this figure
it was enjoyable and i think yeah it was
successful in a few different ways
yeah there's enough easter eggs in there
definitely i'm not a lacanian but i am
in theory adjacent to that sort of thing
so there's enough easter eggs in there
for you to just to keep you happy right
i think there's like
well the easter eggs references like at
one point there is already left's book
the differentialist manifesto
there is like a sophocles there was i
think
i think at one point the um
the
administrator in the office brought in a
book by elaine de baton or something
like that and said it on his desk
that would have been that would have
been out of time that would have been
out of time maybe you meant someone else
i'm probably getting the name wrong uh
there's one by russo i noticed the noble
the noble savage was brought up and it
was in a book on the desk so there's
like yeah there's easter eggs there's
definitely spirits yeah there's a lot of
stuff in there sometimes you have to
pause and go back and like check them
out but uh they're there they're
interesting anyway i just want to say
well you can get this thing on i think
the apple
apple movies app and the
amazon prime
app
it might cost you like four bucks or
whatever it is um but you're not not
everyone's gonna like this movie i
thought we should add i should we should
add that if your favorite film is uh
infinity war yeah
or this or the hangover
this may not be the film for you it all
takes place in one room
it's a one-to-one aspect ratio it's
black and white so it's
the the artsy fartsy bits so if you're
in if you're into lacon and i think
you're gonna like it a lot but if you
are
the type of person who needs to be
constantly stimulated a casual
infotainment consumer maybe not it
really has and i think this is
intentional uh it feels like like a like
a play like it's got that kind of like
theater
feel to it um and in fact as we as i
found out actually in the credits i was
like oh crap oh it is actually based on
a novel and then a play written by betty
milan who
is a brazilian's uh lacanian
psychoanalyst
um and she actually uh was analyzed by
lacan in the 70s late 70s mid 70s
and the novel and the play i think are
loosely based on her analysis though
they're not i i from what i read it's
not like a full out like biographical
account of her i mean in in the film at
least then the name has changed um it's
not betty milan right it's some other
it's another woman and we'll get to that
in a little bit um
so it does have that kind of feel
uh like that kind of theater feel when
you're when you're watching it um i
remember just i actually kept thinking i
was like wow this just like
because the whole thing as as pill says
takes place pretty much the whole thing
takes place in the one room in the
analyst
in the analyst and a lasagne
kind of like uh back and forth and i
don't envy the task of the writer or the
filmmaker who has to make lacan's
writing and methods
understandable and palatable to a wider
audience than they normally would be i
mean after this i went back and read um
i went back and read the mirror stage
and i'm just like oh my [ __ ] god like
i
i read it like
eight years ago and now reading it again
today i've read it a couple times but i
feel like i understand a little tiny bit
more of it every time but like i still
couldn't explain
i couldn't just sit down and explain it
to somebody it's really difficult so
the way i think the balance was like
perfect between a kind of drama you can
follow a story you can kind of follow
and dropping in those things that if
you're sort of in the know
and you are familiar with lacanian
psychoanalysis you get the sense that
there is a solid theoretical
understanding behind this film there's
just enough in there to indicate that
but not too much for the uninitiated to
just become completely lost in
in immigrants and letters of the
unconscious and and
all that stuff
and it's not too explainy and what i
kept going back and forth with is uh
like we think we know lacan because he
read his books but this is someone who
like spoke to the khan was analyzed by
him and then we can ask who is lacan is
it the author you know no
is it the analyst no
so it's uh giving aspects of the same
persona that we ascribe one name to
that's really not one name so i thought
it was interesting to be like
is this her experience in analysis that
made that that wrote this is this the
the writer of the film that added this
in there is this uh someone who's
familiar with lacan's work after the
fact checking it and dropping it in so
it was interesting trying to figure out
you know what's unsaid as the movie says
and lacan himself quote says something
to the effect in there of uh
the analyst is always acting but
pretending not to be right and it's
worth mentioning too that the director
uh richard
letties or leeds god we're gonna have to
find out how to pronounce that last name
but
um he
actually has a phd
in
i believe it's some kind of like uh
history of psychology uh i wasn't
exactly clear like i saw him mention it
in an interview that i watched
but on his own website
i don't know well you can ask him and
yeah we will we will find out we will
half an hour in fake time exactly
exactly so i will find out exactly but
the point is he has like a real he has
he has a real understanding like like
like an academic understanding of lacan
i think based on that that background
but anyway i just wanted to say it was
really refreshing because of the
depictions of
especially psychoanalysis and therapy in
you know popular
media or even academics i could say in
popular media they're either like
savant geniuses who are anti-social
the only thing they care about is their
object of study and then especially when
psychoanalysis is depicted in film or or
tv
it's
you know tell me about your childhood
with some like caricature of freud but
this
shows the method as someone who's done
analysis it really shows the method and
it
picks up on the right parts
like where there's those fallings in
language i think at one point she says
language trips and falls over itself
and then you as the analyzand are
thinking why did i say that and then
that's the thing that's in your your
mind for the rest of the week yeah so i
don't know should we pills do you want
to talk a little bit more about lacanian
analytic method before we get into
kind of giving a
very like brief setup of what's what the
movie is about yeah we should actually
we haven't talked about lacan directly
for a while so maybe we should refresh
on that like as opposed to the other
psychoanalysts melanie klein
who deals often with child childhood and
play and that kind of thing and freud i
think everybody knows freud
uh the bill young and melanie klein
yeah
let's not mention carl jung let's not
bring him
but anyway the thing that lacan is most
uh different from his colleagues in in
that respect and even the psychoanalytic
association that he got kicked out of
slash left
is this emphasis on language and this is
something i think the film got
very fascinatingly correct
focusing on her words her reflections on
her words and there's also a few
idiosyncrasies of lacan himself that
come out in the film
like
him ending sessions abruptly sometimes
the sessions would be 10 minutes long
and he'd just say okay we're done i'll
see you next time and then demand the
same payment for every session
he's talked about this too this
demanding payment thing is you cannot
have
you cannot have a what appears to be a
friendship with an analyst end the
analyst must be the figure that is
outside this is a paid relationship and
there's stories of him like sitting
while the while the analyzand is
speaking you know pouring their heart
out over their trauma he's sitting there
like counting the franks and clicking
the coins on his desk and they go you're
not listening to me and then he'll go
okay the session's done
but the whole point of this you're not
listening to me i guess the mindset to
these days would be i'm a consumer i
have paid for your time you owe me this
time and then if lacan is the genius
that many of us think he is that he's
trying to provoke that response to say
look i'm not your dad i'm not your buddy
i don't owe you anything and just
because you paid me doesn't define my
responses to you yeah which is different
from a therapist right i often bash
therapy as opposed to psychoanalysis
for for specifically that reason
yeah for sure and i think there's a like
the the part about the variable length
sessions too
is this idea to about like
that if i i think like part of the
theory behind it is like if the the
analyzand has this idea of like okay
i've got like 50 minutes or whatever
then like their unconscious is going to
kind of like set themselves up
so that
um they can protect like kind of the
insights around it within the framework
of that time so if you say ahead of time
like okay like the timing is going to be
what it is
then like you your unconscious can't
adapt
uh to
the length of the session and therefore
um the analyst instead in the lacanian
context can kind of intervene and stop
and and i think it's a form of
intervention to basically get the
analysan to reflect so if there's like a
moment a puncture kind of that happens
um or like i guess what what some might
call like a potential breakthrough at
least from the analysts
perspective then they can just stop the
session and sort of force the analysis
and to sit with with with what happened
and how it ended that's the theory
behind it
i don't know
i say i don't know when you get up true
you're going to leave me with i don't
know i can't stand this way of ending a
session this sudden and and brutal
interruption
one hundred francs
i didn't withdraw any money
then go and get it
i've heard less charitable
interpretations and stories of like you
know like lacan collecting 100 francs
from you know like 20 patients a day
because he's having these like short
like 10 minute sessions and that it's
like a money grab so you know you can
there's a way of interpreting it
cynically i think the theory behind it
is kind of interesting but i think you
would have to like for that to be the
case it would have to be
the case that sometimes you'd have
sessions that would go on for three
hours right because like it would keep
going so it'd have to be variable both
ways
which apparently it was i don't know for
sure
of the three of us i probably
may have the most kind of stereotypical
illusions about what
goes on in psychoanalytic therapy
but my basic notion is that it's all
sort of based on again the freudian
talking cure
the idea that
you just you get the person to speak
you get the patient and alison to speak
and the
analyst acts you know plays that role
but and acts like a blank canvas
whatever background you need
in a certain sense whatever psychodrama
is working itself out through
your language and through your the
narratives you're telling about yourself
the analyst is supposed to be almost
like a blank canvas or ready to adopt
any
sort of oppositional roles that emerge
in the sort of con so it's like if it's
a problem with a kind of
primordial father or mother
or
any kind of thing like that the analyst
is ready there to be that canvas you
need on which to paint your
sort of
i guess like paint your unconscious in a
certain way but at least that the
talking cure
anyway it seems like the the basic thing
to
bring up first yeah i had an analyst and
i kind of asked why do you even do the
laying down thing why do you lay down on
a couch
instead of like talk face to face
and he described it as you need to both
be looking at the same thing which is
not really the thing
you need to be like they're they're a
functionary where you bounce your
language off of but it's so that you can
see the thing that you're talking about
and the
the positionality
is supposed to help with that which is
again i think it's unique to
psychoanalysis the laying on the couch
as opposed to other forms of therapy
like cognitive behavioral therapy
definitely you can also see there what
the
the
symbolic imaginary triad how they show
their functions and the purpose of
analysis because
it's not
what do you not know about yourself that
you have to learn but it's what do you
know about yourself that you don't want
to know
or what do you know about yourself that
you want to pretend that you don't know
and that's where the the loop is the
lying loop where you're lying to
yourself about what you already know so
yeah in my experience
you learn
what you know you don't want to know
rather than learning what you don't know
yeah for sure oh go ahead
i was just going to add to that say
there's a certain
there's a certain
thing that the analyst needs to do in
those situations is ferret out
avoidance
and when you're trying to avoid the
issues and you're substituting some
other
less important issue for the real issue
when you're talking about one thing
in order to avoid talking about
something else which i feel like
you know that move that that film made
me feel like you know someone who's into
theory that's what i'm doing all the
time is avoiding the real problems
and never really you know but what like
am i listening to myself am i listening
to my body like i'm i'm putting myself
in the audiences that lacan is speaking
to when i'm reading his papers the the
silk of the expert audience but i never
put myself in the position of the and
alice and to think of like am i really
you know am i living out these
principles or am i just sort of learning
them at a distance and otherwise you
know
persisting in my otherwise repressive
ways
yeah i think there's a there's a great
line from the film where she goes
sure she says to look on while she's
being analyzed i don't even know why i
am in france and then he there's a
voiceover where he says she doesn't know
why she's in france because she doesn't
listen to herself speak
speak
i don't really know why i'm in france
she doesn't know why because she doesn't
listen to you yeah that's the line i was
thinking of that he kind of goes on in
his monologue which i love those little
almost internal lacanian monologues i
thought those are crucial but that's
just how it made me feel like man i'm do
i do this all the [ __ ] time i'm
probably a mess if i did psycho analysis
now the person would probably just be
like nah
you're too far gone sorry buddy we can't
train we can't train you at this age i
actually think it's it might be worth
just kind of like giving a brief
uh setup of like what happens in the
film because i think actually it's it i
kind of decided as as i was listening to
you both talk that
it's worth kind of telling the audience
okay so the movie is about this woman um
siri emma right who who is going to who
went to france from brazil
um to get analysis from lacan
and and like the basic setup is i think
she she had two miscarriages and and had
an issues with her i think i don't know
if it was her boyfriend or her husband i
i forget if they were actually married
or not but they tr they tried to have
children and that like led to a kind of
crisis and like without spoiling it so
that's basically the setup of why she's
there
um
but i did also want to say something
about uh psych about lacanian
psychoanalytic technique
um
you know one of the things you uh eric
you were saying you were talking about
how the the psycho analyst acts as kind
of like a black canvas and i've got here
i've been i've been looking and what
seeing the film
um made me want to revisit uh bruce
fink's um a clinical introduction to the
canadian psychoanalysis because i think
he goes over some really like
key aspects of just like the technique
itself right so one of the things he
talks about is like that the analyst and
i think this
in a way shows up in the film
um
has to combat this idea of like the
subject supposed to know which means
like when you go into analysis i think
there's a tendency of the analysis to
want to think of the analyst as some
kind of figure of authority right that
they have knowledge
that they're going to share with you
and that's actually like not what the
analyst is supposed to do right the
analytic the only authority uh think
talks about this
if there is an authority to be respected
in the analytic setting it is the
manifestations of the unconscious
in in the analyze and slips mistakes
expressions of surprise and so on right
so
the so that's and actually that fits
into what you were just saying uh that
quote in the movie right where he says
oh she would know you know if she heard
herself talk because the authority right
the actual authority is
their own unconscious their own speaking
and i thought i also thought it was
interesting
in the film when he says i think he
comments in one of the voice over parts
uh the lecon character you know that
people very rarely some people go
through their whole life right like not
actually hearing themselves speak not
actually hearing themselves right and
it's like the analyst
uh
setting is meant really to be where you
can hear yourself speak and i think that
fits into what you were saying pills
about why is it that analysts want you
to sit on the couch not facing them
right because
if you are seeing the other person and
this is another thing that comes up in
the book by the way if you are seeing
your analyst as a person
in front of you right then that can
distract you from just listening to
yourself right so like by not looking at
someone you can there's a more chance
this is at least the theory behind right
there's more chance you're gonna hear
the words you're using you're gonna hear
yourself talk right where
and i think this is where the
psychoanalytic theory or the lacanian
theory of like the imaginary comes in
if you look if you look face to face you
get all kinds of weird imaginary ideas
fantasies about the other person and
this is another thing that has to be
combated in analysis right that you know
thinking about the analyst
as a person can get in the way right you
you start imagining as an other if
you're thinking about what they're
thinking of you then you're not hearing
yourself exactly right exactly exactly
so that's one of another things that
they're always combating right is like
you have to make sure you in fact you
have to the the goal of the analyst is
to be an other
but like not another person like the cap
the capital o other uh as opposed to
which is the other in yourself right to
be able to hear yourself
i don't know if we have any psychoanal
psychoanalyst psychoanalysis cynics in
the audience but one thing that struck
me was how easy it would be to see this
all as just a grift because the only
thing that look or one of the only
things lacan says except for a few
probing questions are you know go on
continue speaking yeah speak speak more
and then
what else and then collects his hundred
bucks at the end of the day so
it's totally like
oh this is the easiest job ever you sit
there and ask someone to speak but i
guess it's uh what separates someone
who's who's capable and good at it is
can you push
into that that direction
or not because if you're just looking at
it from the outside it almost seems like
well this is the this is the easiest
grift ever the easiest like self-help
guru thing you don't even have to give
advice yeah you can't even tell if he's
listening or not like it's or like you
know it can almost sound like but i
think that really is the task to like
listen and to know when to intervene but
for sure it can definitely seem
uh i could see why
it would it could seem like a grift i
will say
um on the like i don't know i wouldn't
say that i'm a psychoanalysis
cynic
but i have been somewhat persuaded by so
my stepdad's a psychiatrist and he and i
don't know if i've ever talked about
this on the podcast but
he's a psychiatrist and he started off
training to be a freudian analyst
and he was in analysis but he felt
uh i don't know if he would say that it
was like he thought it was a grift but
he what he what he didn't like about it
was he felt like the method was getting
in the way of the humanity of it which
maybe is the point right of analysis
right you're supposed to dehumanize in
the sense right like that all the stuff
we were just talking about
um
but he was persuaded by reading um a lot
of the research there was like a pretty
famous i think research paper in
psychiatry or maybe it was psychology
about how the most successful
um therapists of every stripe
were the ones where the people who had
self-reported the best outcomes of their
therapy and this this was like a bunch
of different types of therapists with
all kinds of methods right whether it's
cognitive behavioral therapy whether
it's lacanian analysis whether it's you
know humanists whatever it is and you
just said that like
you know there wasn't really like that
good evidence to say that one had better
outcomes than the other but what they
did find was that the patients who said
that they who had the best self-reported
outcomes had therapists who they felt
like heard them and were listening to
them and they felt like some kind of
like rapport like they felt like they
were being heard
um
it didn't matter if they're freudians
didn't matter if they were like you know
cognitive behavioral therapists so he
was kind of persuaded that you know the
method doesn't really matter
uh it's kind of like the approach that
you take
and he himself adopts kind of like a
grab bag of different methods that kind
of like make sense to him and i and i
and i will say that it seems intuitive
to me that
psychoanalysts are maybe at greatest
risk maybe this is wrong
but at a certain risk of
almost fetishizing their method where
they're just like they where they follow
it like procedurally
and like don't really pay the attention
it's like they're paying more attention
to the method than they are the person
that's there with them
um and so i don't know i mean again this
is coming from someone who's never
studied psychology or like practiced it
but that seems right to me
well one charge that's sometimes levied
against lacan is that a larger
proportion of his uh analyzants
committed suicide
and i there is also a pushback to that
which is to say uh or his supporters say
that uh he also took on the most
difficult
hopeless
quote-unquote cases right that you know
that would that would probably be the
outcome anyway so i don't know there is
a debate about that about whether he was
in
whether he was ethical or whether the
method itself
is ethical
but can you imagine i can't imagine what
i would do if i heard my
analyst in the back of the room like
counting the money that i gave him and
just being like
dude yeah there's a part there's a part
in the film too i deserve love yeah
yeah exactly exactly you know and i
think
i i often thought to myself that i
wonder if like i i've always wanted to
be an analysis um just because i think
it would be interesting um
but i think
i feel like there are probably a lot of
people who are like really suffering
a lot
and it does strike me that like
psychoanalysis would be really hard for
those people i think because it's just
like i think it's like extremely
challenging because it does force you to
confront yourself
and i think the problem is so many
people who go into therapy
like are have such a hard time doing
that already and then you go to this
method that like forces you to do this
and like doesn't hold your hand at all
like it doesn't surprise me that it just
wouldn't work for those kinds of people
i guess like i feel like you have to
already have some kind of like a
stronger
constitution in yourself to be able to
handle what it asks of you well there's
always a reason like if you are in
analysis there's a reason
for that i mean unless you got committed
or something so you know
i guess even to show up there you know
that something's wrong and believe that
it can be fixed now it's usually not the
thing that you think is wrong going in
there for example in this film she goes
in
because she's having marital problems
and comes out
and it's a different problem i won't i
won't spoil it yeah but it's it's
something else that she had to realize
about herself but what i really also
liked about this film as opposed to
i don't know marriage counseling is
there's a definite end point in analysis
like now you're finished
um and that's that doesn't mean that you
you are ever like truly finished in
terms of uh growing as a person and all
that but if there's one thing that is
the the tr the trauma point or the hinge
point that you keep cycling or the
repetition that we speak about with
reference to the khan if you keep
repeating that one event then there is a
definite point at which you realize and
cease
the repetition which is the goal and
there might be if you if you have
multiple traumas you might have to do
multiple
multiple routes through that repetition
but i thought that was it was a good
point to end on because
the analyzand realizes that she got what
she needed from it not that he decided
it was over
yeah
yeah
didn't he kind of decide though didn't
he kind of decide at one point in the
film or he's just like you got what you
needed like you figured it out
he said that in voiceover actually oh
okay he didn't he's like she's done but
he didn't let her finish until she
realized she was done
oh you're right you're right you're
totally right i should've been paying
better attention
yeah it's like he he noticed the
breakthrough happened but it hadn't
quite sunk in yet so it's like okay has
to continue can't stop too early because
then
maybe it will regress but i was going to
ask about that that that repetition
because i got the sense
you know i've read some guterree too and
he kind of emphasizes this aspect of
psychoanalysis as it helps you get past
blockages right when you get you get
blocked up you get stuck i'm guessing as
a result of some kind of trauma and you
constantly just repeat that tr you
repeat that trauma over and over again
and you can't move past it and it stops
you from moving forward in your life it
stops you from
in some cases you know being able to
become a mother right
releasing some kind of tension
that's affecting you that you had
between you and your father that
is continuing to be repeated
i get this sense also of of war trauma
right a lot of psychoanalytic theory has
drawn from returning soldiers and they
find that they tend to
live their traumatic experiences over
and over and over again that kind of
repetition compulsion
so there's a certain sense that
psychoanalysis is about helping you get
past these blockages and
allow you to i mean i like these lines
about allowing you to take control of
your past rather than become a victim of
it
allowing you to
to sh to to write your own story rather
than kind of being a slave to
[Music]
history which is when you're trying to
repress it because the repressed always
returns the ancestors never you know
stay dead they always come back
yeah that's that's what psychoanalysis
seems to be about in a very broad sense
yeah that says that does that was a good
moment um when he says something about
how
because she's sort of the the anna lozan
she's resisting
like a certain or at least she's
questioning like why is there like this
obsession with going back and like look
like examining these things and i think
he says something like um
you know those who aren't
aware of the past are going to reenact
it all the time
although i wonder
you know do you think there's something
this is something i've often thought
about like psychoanalysis or it's like a
critique i've wondered about which is
like
is it does it have like is it too
rationalistic in this sense in the sense
that it's like okay if you just have
like knowledge of something somehow it
won't bother you anymore right it's like
so it like it almost like it almost
overly cognizant cognizes trauma or
cognizes
psychological disturbances by being like
well all you need to know is be aware of
it and then somehow that's gonna like
make you better i don't know i i have an
answer to that though because i
i realized kind of the repetition that i
was doing through analysis i realized
the repetition i was doing
and i still do it
right right it's not like it's not like
i'm suddenly a better person right but
the difference is subjectively then
you're not
you don't feel trapped by it at least
when you screw up the next time you can
say look here's i know why this happened
so you have a story to go with it um
whereas before
whereas then you're accountable for it
and then you can like then then if you
like if you [ __ ] up your relationship
with somebody then you can apologize to
them for it having known
what was your responsibility there well
i guess because in the past you would
have maybe or someone not necessarily
you would have just had all kinds of
like rationalizations and defense
mechanisms and wouldn't have been able
to see the core of it
it would have been repetition without
knowledge whereas now it would be
repetition
plus knowledge so i don't think it's it
doesn't solve your behavior but it
solves the
the repetition which is the
unconsciousness of your behavior
yeah there's a certain there's a certain
way in which it's a symbolic resolution
of a real conflict
and in psychoanalysis the real conflict
is always
you know inherent in the constitution of
any subject
there's a kind of real
at the core of it which is a kind of
fracture or a split the split subject
which i guess i guess the have the
non-knowledge of that or the attempts at
repression or cheap solutions is is
going to manifest as repetition
compulsions
which manifest in you know in your
language in your speech in your symbolic
life
your social life in a certain sense
i think this is also a big concept in
like claude levy strauss and friedrich
jameson the ideas of of symbolic
resolution to real conflicts
and i guess
psychoanalysis seems to take on a
version of that as well with its focus
on language and symbols and signs
one thing i i don't think this is a
spoiler and you can let me know i'll cut
it out if it is
but the very end of the film the final
question that lacan wants her to answer
because we've kind of given her
fictional biography a little bit she
comes from brazil
and goes to paris and she thinks that
she wants to go study with lacan because
he's this
man of renown and a very famous analyst
but
the thing that he gets her to admit that
he suspected all along is that she
wanted to
do
psychoanalysis not in her mother tongue
which would be brazilian portuguese but
she wanted she wanted to do it in french
and she kind of realizes that that's a
defense mechanism which is her final
realization that makes her realize okay
i can go home now because she was
defending herself against the trauma of
her mother tongue and her ancestry and a
bunch of other parts of the film that
we're not going to uh spoil for you but
that's it i love that language bit that
language was ultimately the problem
because that is lacan
which is ultimately the problem exactly
and there's a good part without without
spoiling it there there's a good scene
where
um she she reports having hallucinations
and the things she's having
hallucinations on she comes to discover
like there's a word um that like is
standing in for something else in her
life and like that's a very like
lacanian moment in the film and i
thought that was the place
the displacement placement in the
symbolic and in the words not the not
not what they mean exactly it would be
much more freudian to be like okay what
is this
what does this hallucination represent
rather than oh it's actually just a word
exactly it's about the language part of
it and i think that that the the whole
part about um the mother tongue is
interesting because i think there's also
a scene in the movie where lacan
suggests he's like because
pretty early in the film i think she
expresses the the female character she
expresses frustration with like not
being understood in france the film
isn't english but it's supposed to be
like in france obviously
and then
um and then he kind of suggests well i
can get you like a portuguese
uh analyst right and and and then she's
like very hostile she threatens to yeah
she threatens to leave analysis
basically and and she has a
rationalization for it right which is
well i'm brazilian these are portuguese
so it's going to be different it's not
even going to be the same like what's
the point i came here so it's funny and
then of course at the end of the film
you realize and these are light spoilers
but like whatever i think it actually
i don't think it matters
light spoil but it's also this uh the
center of look on that everybody knows
is the unconscious is structured like a
language
so it's not just whereas freudian
psychoanalysis and i might be wrong
about this but freudian psychoanalysis
it seems to me is like okay what does a
wolf
represent what does a rat represent
these different these different um
analysis that freud had it's like we we
need to get to the meaning of the image
whereas in lacon the meaning is in like
the phoneme that's what i mean
it's in just the phoneme that represents
something else unconsciously because
your unconscious is much more attuned to
these minor differences in language that
we forget
but you remember it
as a kid and like i said i'm on vacation
now so i got like nephews who are
learning how to talk
and their slips of of these phonemes are
really interesting to me not that i'm
psychoanalyzing them but the little
slips of phoneme are interesting to me
because we forgot that we learned that
this is one of one of the pills-isms
that i always repeat you forgot how
difficult it was to learn it it took you
it took you years of practicing every
single day and anything that we
do for years of practicing every single
day we're going to forget how difficult
it was at the beginning but in this film
at least it has a great example and
probably the original
source material as well of how like
that's not natural in in that sense it's
not it's not easy and you build up these
associations where you can slip from one
word into another and that's where
language stumbles over itself because
your unconscious is structured like a
language yeah that's something i really
liked about this film is that
sarajevo's sort of
her being brazilian and her focus the
focus on her language and her culture is
in a way convenient
at foregrounding what you just said
pills because in lacanian the lacanian
unconscious foregrounds
the unconscious is being structured like
a language
much more so than it does
um the unconscious the freudian
unconscious being a kind of repository
of instinctive drives
and even you know he he he kind of opens
up one of his articles or he he says
this in one of his articles you know the
psychoanalytic experience discovers in
the unconscious
the whole structure of language and
that's language in the sense that so sir
ferdinand de saussure would use the term
language existing as an entire total
structure
which as you learn and and incorporate
lang you become like a kind of microcosm
of
long
and so you know he says i've alerted
informed minds which means his expert
audiences i guess to the extent to which
the notion that the unconscious is
merely the seed of the instincts will
have to be rethought so it's not
it's not instinctive but it's that
that foregrounding that language element
and in a sense her situation was
convenient
for foregrounding that aspect of
lacanian psychoanalysis because this if
he was just performing psychoanalysis on
another french person right you wouldn't
necessarily have it would
i think just maybe
filmically and directorially it would be
a little harder to foreground the
importance of language
insi in lacanian psychoanalysis but
i thought that was a really
good solution to bringing that out
because
like i said you know lacan really
incorporates you know
so sir and modern linguistics into his
methods
right as compared to jung because jung's
like library of archetypes is purely
imaginary and he almost gives no no
credence to
language except as a vehicle to convey
the imaginary
whereas or like you said the sur lacan
french tradition is very focused on the
language itself
not not what it represents but as what
it
does as a machine is a function
yeah so like you know
freud's mechanisms of the unconscious
the way that the unconscious works for
freud is through condensation and
displacement
right where
a symbol can acquire a kind of catheter
or
you know emotional investment
and then displacement is the second
mechanism which then takes that
condensed energy
and switches it for a different symbol
so you have this kind of looping
condensation displacement condensation
displacement
and in linguistic terms that's metaphor
and metonymy metaphor metaphor is
condensation metonomy is displacement
and it and then that links into the
cesarean sign of the signifier and the
signified and the relationship between
those two and the ultimate sort of
importance of the signifier over the
signified
because that's how
you know the unconscious works the
unconscious is structured like a
language let's take on linguistics and
look at metaphor and autonomy
and see how metaphors and dreams and
metonyms
i mean metonyms are you know using a
part to represent a whole kind of thing
and metaphors replacing one hole with
another sort of thing right i think i'd
like to
bring bring back some of this structural
analysis of language to the uh
to the public discourse these days
because everyone's extremely obsessed
with
the way words are used what words
represent and not really what words are
anymore
yeah no that's that's interesting do you
have an example in mind i mean you're
right no i don't not today
not today yeah i mean yeah that's that's
good well you know the
the interesting part about the return to
german idealism from a psychoanalytic
perspective is that you have to read
the language stuff back into german
idealism because it
it's really not a central element
until maybe you get to
hegel maybe not even hegel maybe the
romantics make a much bigger deal of
language
and
you know by the time you're at le con
language linguistics and the so-syrian
understanding of languages is crucial
it's been deeply incorporated into the
psychoanalytic method
yeah no i think so and i mean earlier
because i was kind of mentioning that
some critiques are you can get too
caught up in the method but i think
that's probably true of other things too
like cognitive behavioral therapy is
like a very specific method as well
i don't know i just don't know enough i
guess but that's i'm just kind of just
like giving second hand earlier like
what my psychiatrist step dad has said
in the past he's not particularly a fan
of
cognitive behavioral therapy
either
one of the
you know one of the big stereotypes
about psychoanalysis is that
the
the ego the damaged ego of the patient
is supposed to be replaced by the
perfect ego of the analyst
which
i i think lacan actually mentions that
that is actually kind of how the
american ego psychologists treat it in
some ways and that it's a very flawed
method because the analyst is known is
also imperfect
that's what you were saying earlier
about like we go in
expecting answers because this is the
subject supposed to know
yeah and we want answers why and i think
serie amo
brings us up a little bit it's like
always more questions and never answers
from you
just more questions it's almost it's
almost as if you're more interested in
what i'm not saying than what i am
saying
and he just goes
that's true yeah
session over
like whoa and then he stops yeah he
stops it at that moment too like the
whole variable length sessions right she
asked that question he's like you're
right and then he stops it right because
he wants her to sit with that thought
right
yeah why are you getting up this brought
up a question that i really want to ask
the director
and it's
i don't know that i don't like it it
just seemed very uh puzzling to me
is that
lacan well both of them have their
voiceover so they're they're speaking
right they're speaking to each other and
one thing that a film can do that like a
play can't unless you have maybe a
soliloquy or something pre-recorded or
pre-recorded yeah
but they use voiceover to tell us what
lacan is thinking
while he's analyzing
and i think at maybe at one point early
on i i might be wrong about this but i
think she gets a voiceover as well for a
little bit yeah and i was wondering what
you guys thought because this to me
in a way really disrupted the
psychoanalytic experience of the movie
which is just you know psycho analysis
sessions but to hear what he's thinking
i think it's
really good for like a viewer's
perspective especially if you don't know
what psychoanalysis is all about is like
oh this is the end goal that he's trying
to
uh get to
but there's an attempt using these
voice-overs to
subjectivize
lacan
as well which is exactly the opposite
intention of of
the psychoanalytics session
so i wondered if you had any thoughts
about
you know like is this a choice for the
viewers i think that's obvious but is it
did it change your experience of
watching this the puzzle of her
uh repetition unfold
or did it distract from that maybe yeah
you know i think that is probably the
one place
where i had mixed feelings about the
film um
so i on the one hand i thought it was
interesting
and useful especially there was like a
couple moments i'm trying to remember
exactly what happened where
the voice over to like what he's
thinking
and then to what she's thinking and it's
what's interesting about it is just like
how different it is how like they're how
they're thinking totally past each other
kind of like how she's not picking up on
what he's trying to do
and like i think that what's good and
useful about that is
um it's kind of like gives you an
insight into like the difficulty of
being an analyst or like what the
analyst is trying to do
and how like the the analyzand can have
a hard time picking up on that but on
the other hand
i think like from like a narrative
perspective i think what what felt a
little bit uneven to me about the film
was that it seemed like it both was
focusing much more on syriama
but then there were like parts where as
you were saying pills like
subjectivizing lacan
and because there are those scenes where
he's on the phone talking to his doctor
right because like there's there's kind
of like a subplot of how like lacan
himself is sick at the time which he was
i think he died shortly after
um when the movie was taking place in
the late 70s
and that part felt a little bit
underdeveloped like it felt like the
film wanted to give you some insight
into who lacan the person was and like
what kind of struggles he was going
through
and maybe that fits into like including
the voiceovers of of lacan himself but
in general it felt
much less developed underdeveloped
compared to like what we get about into
like seriema if that makes sense
right i think i would agree with that
and say either fully humanize him and
show that he's like
worried about his lunch and worried
about his kid and he's just a normal guy
but then he comes into the session and
is no longer a normal guy because he has
to function as the analyst there
or keep them entirely separate or just
leave
the subjectivizing of him out and keep
him as this guru mystical figure but i
understand certainly why it was done
because
if you don't yeah if you're if you're
not familiar with his writings and all
this background stuff then it becomes
unclear why he's doing what he's doing
yeah that's the thing maybe it would be
more interesting to be unclear with what
he's doing because the end result would
be the same right but i don't know i
thought
it's hard i don't know
i can't say whether or not i would have
made it or not made it but it was the
one part that i thought stuck out to me
as
i don't even want to say it was wrong i
don't want to say it was right i was it
was it was puzzling i think it added a
a knot into
the relationship that i wasn't expecting
i i agree yeah i have a very similar
take i have a a bit of a half-baked take
on this
about the the lacan voice-overs and what
that gives us in the film
which
i agree i kind of wanted more but in
another sense i thought that those were
just kind of delicate notes that were
put in there that if we did get more it
might have ruined a bit of the
it would have ruined a little bit of the
immersion in the main story
but what i really liked about it was it
established this is my take anyway it
seemed to establish parallels between
lacan and the patient right because
lacan
is portrayed as refusing to get some
kind of operation right
that is supposedly he's he is unable to
face his own death
and he's supposed to get some kind of
operation done
but he doesn't want to live a life of
pain i don't know if i'm ruining too
much going through all this but this
establishes a perfect parallel between
serie ma who is
for various reasons using therapy
in france and french to avoid the real
problems and and and
something about you know not getting an
operation after the first miscarriage
and that sort of thing came up and this
seemed to draw a direct parallel to
lacan who's thinking about his own
daughter
and how she will be left without a
father in the same way that seriema kind
of was right and he obviously doesn't
want to leave his daughter with the same
sort of emotional baggage that serie ma
has to deal with
but he doesn't want to live a life of
pain he any but he's this is creating
another thing that you would need
psychoanalysis for he's unable to face
his own death why there's probably some
other issue that he can't really get to
on his own
that is going on there but it seemed not
only to establish the kind of
imperfectness of the analysis
but also it added this nice like sort of
narrative kind of or thematic parallel
to serie ma's own situation
which was that she was
you know she's going to therapy but
there is a deep current of like
avoidance
driving the whole entire
thing this repression that he's got to
fare it out and so why are you doing
this why are you avoiding talking about
the real issues kind of thing and you
know you can see lacan almost in the
grips in his very old age
right this is like the last
this took place from 1974 to 1977
which was less than 10 years before
lacan's real historical death
and so that's that's what i thought
again another aspect that the lacanian
the lacan voiceovers added anyway
just to build on that there is a
difference um kind of what i said
earlier about repetition plus knowledge
is different
because she she didn't know why she
refused treatment
but he did and he said i know this is
what's expected of me i know that the
doctor wants me to do this and my
daughter wants me to do this and
everyone wants me to
not be sick anymore
but i want to be sick
i i don't know if that i don't know if
you'd call that the same kind of refusal
but he's not being
um
or he has he i guess he has knowledge of
the repetition that he's performing
there saying i'd i'd rather be dead and
it's in a way like the specter of a life
and pain is preventing him from taking
the chance at living a longer healthy
life
maybe the operation would go fine
doesn't matter it's his kind of fantasy
of of living in pain
that is now again blocking him up
and so lacan probably himself needs
psychoanalysis after this
if they ever do a uh if they ever do a
sequel which which would not make sense
good
self-contained
film
that part has to be fictional so i
wonder maybe we should ask the director
what what the purpose behind that was or
if we already got it
yeah
take
the purpose of what yeah i mean i think
like you're talking about what eric was
just saying which i agree that that does
seem like plausibly the intent
of what he was up to
i think you know and this comes from
someone who like
doesn't [ __ ] know like much about
cinema
um but i guess it it see it struck me
that like that if that was the attempt
maybe it wasn't 100 successful
um but i also think that it would be
it's like where we said at the beginning
like this is such a
monumental task to make a film about
lacan that can actually capture some of
the theory and practice
in like a compelling way which i think
for the most part was actually quite
successful
um and then these like little things
kind of like
it's just hard to know how the film
would have come across if it tried to
like develop that more it might not like
i'm trying to imagine how it could have
been done as a non-filmmaker again and i
just don't know
and it might just be like audience
service too which would there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that almost
all of our films are pure audience
service and this one's clearly not
there's i don't know if if we
i don't know how much longer we want to
go but there's another there's one last
little
kind of thread that uh i don't know if
if we can untangle it
it was the gender thing that ran through
it right did you notice
after
the second meeting
he holds up a newspaper
and he's reading from this newspaper
and funny enough the part the newspaper
faces the camera and says and it says it
like big french headline
mao dead at 82 years old
it wasn't mentioned just interesting
funny there's a lot of easter eggs like
that
yeah
yeah a little historical references
and but then on the other side of the
paper which he was looking at lacan was
reading he said heart has a gender it
was something about the heart having a
gender and the difference and he's kind
of like musing to himself oh even even
the heart has sex
has a sex right and and there's this
sort of
the strand of of a kind of um
you know her desire to remain sexless
and her body betraying her
really played into
obviously the issues with the father
the father wants all the affection for
himself
and leaves her unable to
choose a substitute i don't know if
that's the right way to put it
um
but
running even underneath that is her
desire to be sexless she was brought up
almost in a boyish way right like she's
trained to be competitive she was
encouraged to do judo
and compete for grants even her even her
professional life is is
run over by this competitiveness and
she's she's there on a grant the money
she's using to pay him is some grant
she's obtained to go to paris and live
there for six years or whatever it was
and get psychoanalysis
uh
but that gender thing is weird because
then it kind of
comes up again
later in the film as well
but that initial moment where it comes
up
with the heart having a gender
and this sort of
you know your biological sex betrays
your fantasies in a certain way i don't
know if that's
codified into psychoanalysis
it is and i this is something i'm gonna
be very careful about choosing my words
over but it's an easter egg again to one
of the last
things that lacan wrote was uh i think
it's in uh one of the seminars it's
called sexuation and difference
and
he got uh you know what we would call
cancelled by
a lot of
feminists
for writing this but he says in there
and it's very much misinterpreted i have
to let our audience know that it's
misinterpreted
but he says there is no female subject
the
the subject has a masculine signifier
and the female represents the lack of
that now immediately you have to
understand this has nothing to do with
biology the film's mixing it in so maybe
we can untangle it a little bit but it
has only to do
with signifiers so he's not saying
anything about genders and body parts
but i think what this film is bringing
in there is the reference to that part
and if the uh
if the author of this book
is
a psychoanalyst the brazilian lady can
you wrote her name betty milan was the
real one
yeah so i i wonder yeah
it seems to me like that must have some
uh reference in the source material that
was not fully dealt with in the film but
i think it's probably
uh lacan's sexual indifference that's
being referenced elliptically there
yeah like i i remember reading in the
mirror stage that he compares you know a
child looking in the mirror and
recognizing himself in the mirror
he compares that which is a much sort of
more cognitively developed version
of like a pigeon right how a pigeon
develops right like like the female
gonads of a pigeon doesn't develop until
it sees another one of its species right
and there's a sort of parallel there
between a child spotting itself in a
mirror obviously animals can't really
recognize their images in mirrors
i mean we think some dogs do you know
when you when your poodle gets a haircut
it's depressed and sitting in front of
the mirror okay maybe it's maybe it's
that but in in the sort of
psychoanalytic story of development that
moment of of of
identification
of the child who has this wobbly
unsupportable body with this sort of
nice upright image in the mirror and
then that becomes the imago and thus the
sort of imaginary and the symbolic split
is then sort of primordially established
there i'm probably getting that
explanation wrong but there is again
sexuation is activated
by sociality in a certain way seeing
the form or gestalt of your own image
outside you and then identifying with it
animals do this too right like you know
stories about you know certain phases
of
bird development don't start until
the the mother is cooing
on while sitting on the eggs or
something like that then that starts
some kind of biological process
i mean like i
even all this is just to say you know
the biological situation
has always kind of played a part and
lacan does seem to pay attention to
you know
you know what would you call an anatomy
and neurology and sort of mainstream
medical research as well
this is uh
we're comparing early and late lacan
here like i said sexuation and
difference is one of the last things
that he wrote but
when he says the woman does not exist
which i think he says straight up it has
nothing to do with the the biol the
biological
category of woman it's about sexuation
being real not something that's uh
imaginary he likes to say a lot of edgy
things that sound crazy he also says
there is no sexual relationship which is
the the phallus and the lack are the two
modes right there's the penis and penis
envy
it's more unfortunate characterization
right which is
you know they're again if i'm i'm
reading about metaphors and autonomy i'm
like okay what is this metaphor of the
false displacing what's the metanym the
signifier what's the whole then and
there's there's a certain kind of
there's a certain kind of metaphorical
clothing going on that's being
interpreted literally
but i don't i don't know i'm not going
to defend it because i don't know enough
about it yeah if we want to be really
edgy about it we can't end
an episode with it we probably have to
do a full episode on it to make sure
that no one
gets their
foot in their mouth or their phallus in
their mouth but one thing that she was
complaining about this at one point
right like everything you know in in
portuguese you know the sea is a
masculine noun in france it's a feminine
noun the bank is masculine in portuguese
and
and in brazilian portuguese and in
french the bank is a feminine now like
and she's just
complaining about these these
these um linguistic cultural differences
that make her
unable to be understood
and
that then lee that connects up with you
know the other kind of gender stuff
going on in the in here as well and
i i just thought i mean
i didn't say we would untangle this
thread but it's it's definitely like
there quite a bit and her
desire almost not to become a woman
and then the marital
issues that result there from
that psychoanalysis brings her to face
is
deeply linked to culture language gender
sex those issues
and one of her main things is to not be
labeled right not just with the gender i
don't want to give that away because
it's like a key plot point but not to be
labeled as a brazilian in france or not
to be labeled by her dialect of
portuguese as opposed to
portugal's dialect of portuguese she's
very resistant to
labels which is resistance to the
process of subjectification that like
you said occurs beginning with the
mirror stage yeah
in the beginning was the word all right
that's the that's the khan's borrowing
from genesis
same job but even in the even in the
sort of
the the story of eve being derivative of
adam of made of his ribs right we're all
kind of primed towards this this
gendered sexualized language thing so i
don't
i don't know how it how that's dealt
with
in the lacanian literature but in this
film it was an interesting tension that
underlay her
problems
yeah i'm looking forward to talking to
uh richard
i think that'll be be the next step i
think this is as good of an
a little bit of a review slash intro as
we can give so uh with that
why don't we end the first half of this
and we will uh
bring on richard to see what he says and
maybe he's already been brought on
depending on how this goes on the
editing room floor
but anyway
and i think it was it was a good
discussion of psychoanalysis too i think
that in our previous discussions of
lacan
we really talked a lot more about the
theory and i think we i think this was a
good a good discussion of the actual
method so because we were we were
avoiding the real issues of course
hopefully our words were not opaque like
things today
yeah yeah exactly
we are not who we are we already are who
we are not wanting to be
there you go yeah yeah and just remember
desire is the desire of the other
don't see you for phase two
[Music]
all right we are now entering part two
of two and as you can probably hear by
my voice i'm actually using a real
microphone this time
we watched the film enjoyed it
reviewed it sort of um we didn't get
some stuff
and we have questions about other stuff
so who better to answer them than the
writer and director of this film
9.4
out of 10 on imdb so
very spicy there
um very nice dude welcome to our humble
podcast mr richard leeds thank you for
being here
my pleasure
so richard let me let me start off here
with something uh broad something easy
you're a filmmaker
perhaps more in the auteur romantique
lineage but the first thing that struck
me about this film in fact the first
thing that shocked me about this film
was that you made the very bold some
might say radical choice of releasing a
film in 2022 without any cgi to speak of
right this is radical so first question
here
what's your take on the uh the state of
cinema in a reality that's more or less
generated by
an ai in disney's basement
you know i think this film i do what i
call in many ways in many levels
um is conscious of limits
and it's not that i've i'm dead set
against a cgi but most of the time it
leaves me not very excited by what i'm
seeing not very stimulated you know it's
just
it's kind of uh like an endless
uh pre-digested
form of food
no so this was very much
uh as you know it takes place
mainly in in the uh the consulting room
of la cong and then a little bit in his
waiting room
and uh in black and white
uh the there are a few uh exterior
scenes uh shots that are in color
but uh working with you know within
those extreme set of limits
for this film
uh was uh tremendously
energizing uh for the crew for the cast
and uh
you know i think we were able to do
things
with these uh set of limitations
uh that surprised me you know honestly
but i've been working you know i've been
uh
interested in lacrosse work
uh going back over 20 years
from when i did a piece of performance
art
uh based on the records of my mother's
brother
who had a psychotic break
when and was a veteran of the second
world war and i was fascinated by how
these records that were intended to tell
a story about him
also told a story about the storytellers
about that time
after the second world war which was
this pivotal moment in the rise of
mental health care
basically because soldiers the young men
were a non-stigmatized patient
population as they say
you know i came with a stack of books
and i said ah
you know i'm reading all this stuff and
he said well you know you really should
meet people who do this work and you'll
have a completely different feel about
it so i started to get to know
all these different clinical groups
um
and the one that you know i formed a
connection to that never left
was uh a lacanian psychoanalytic
association in new york made up mainly
of uh analysts from latin america or
people who wanted to be analysts
in training
and uh
you know um
and it's always been fascinating to me
um
uh you know the mix of interest in the
visual arts in
in literature in philosophy
uh
reading of black con and freud
and uh
so
i stay i've stayed with it i've stayed
interested
and uh this opportunity came along
and um you know i think
uh it's just all those years of
experience
really
uh
made
oh when you know we shot this in 10 days
so it's like being on oh my god
oh yeah
it's like being on i mean
and i was sick as a dog uh and uh didn't
know how i was you know gonna show up
one more time
at five in the morning to do this but
there's so many things even on a film
of this limited size so many things have
to go right but uh
i'm very happy with
what we were able to achieve
so you pretty much answered my next
question which is why lecon lacan's
obscure except to grad students and of
the psychoanalysts may be controversial
if if you even know of him at all but
maybe i'll maybe i'll shift my question
to um what made you choose the source
material which is uh the khan's parrot
it was a play called the main
source was um
called a goodbye doctor a play by um
a brazilian psychoanalyst who's become a
friend uh betty milan
and uh
i was given an opportunity
to uh direct-to-stage reading
for a group of uh
lacanians
but i i was so struck that the material
was
uh both to a
audience of people who
you know spend their lives
uh returning to the work of la calm
uh
palatable or
it had something to say
and at the same time i thought
you know
this could
this is pretty accessible
you know this is really for someone who
knows
nothing about la calm
but you know
hell it's the story of a woman who's
uh you know wanted to have a child she's
had two miscarriages
uh separated from her husband whom she
loves
and uh is feeling uh you know just alone
um you know
a lot of people can relate to that on
one level or another
um so it was it was
thinking wow this is both
uh
something that could appeal to
uh a specialized audience that i have an
affinity to over many many years and
also a broader audience
really made me
kind of
start to begin to think about making the
plunge
i made some changes that i'll mention
right away one is
the play was called goodbye doctor and
there was uh la call was not mentioned
uh so you know calling it ideologue i
made it about
jacques lacall and the other thing was
that in kind of
maybe because betty had done her
analysis with blackhawk she had changed
the story so that the person
who is
facing death is his is the mother of the
analyst not the analyst himself
and i knew in fact that of course it had
been la call who was
uh at that time
uh getting you know this this uh
unwelcomed
uh news
and uh so so i changed that back and
made that
uh those were two i think significant
changes that really
really drive uh the film forward great
yeah i was wondering
kind of an another sort of background
question about uh about yourself
because you you you were talking about
kind of like doing performance art but
also pursuing an academic career and
then the filmmaking and i'm kind of
curious like how those things came
together was one sort of had priority
over the other
and did one another one kind of come
after were they always sort of interests
that sort of co-existed i
had been living
in
france for uh many years and
doing like small jobs and
writing on art for art form for a while
and you know graduate school seemed like
a way
to uh get back to the states
um and
you know the interest that i had had
in the many years since i had been in
school had continued in france i had
friends who had
introduced me to darida and i had
started attending lectures by
dairy dial where they call them superior
and then through
a friend getting afflicted with aids and
kind of starting to think about how
this
theory could be used to really
address
political
uh political issues
i became more interested in
in foucault
and then
so in a way that though you know it's
always been a kind of
difficult
match um i think
you know it's between an interest in
making film
and an interest in subjects that are
usually approached in a
academic setting and then
you know
my first film was about lobotomy a woman
that wants a lobotomy
starring michelle williams
and my the the um
research for my doctoral dissertation
really became the basis for the
screenplay i had
uh walked out on the street and uh to
meet a friend and i said wow i'm reading
about lobotomy this stuff is [ __ ] up
and he said he said well you know my
mother really wanted to get a lobotomy
and she finally succeeded and i was like
what
and he said no no yeah you know she
really
wanted a lobotomy she and then i
realized there had been a small but not
uh
you know a significant
number of people who had read about
lobotomy on the cover of the new york
times um you know the inventor of the
transorbital
uh
you know which really uh
was at a good price point in those days
you know that
the buy the bilateral you needed a
neurosurgeon
uh to diagnose it a a neurologist would
diagnose it a neurosurgeon to perform it
you needed an anesthesiologist
and uh
you know whereas the transorbital you
didn't even need a medical degree
uh the first ones were really used on
with an ice pick and using uh
electroshock for anesthesia so it
brought down to the
price point to a really nice place
where they could really turn these
things out
and uh
so it you know it they they sold like
hotcakes for it for a short time
so and that way i segued back
uh into filmmaking and uh
and and yet have always
you know kind of kept
uh engaged with uh the lacanians you
know again
loving this kind of
uh a reading process that's involved
uh you know i i studied ancient greek as
a as a kid and
uh my first real
attention to uh la call was someone had
asked me to write a version of the
antigone
and uh that day i happened to read an
obituary for laurence bhattai the um i
guess
daughter-in-law
of jacqueline khan
and it mentioned in this obituary
that uh lack call had brought to her
when she was in prison
for
uh protesting against a french
i you know uh involvement in algeria
uh he had brought to her
his
portion i think of his seventh seminar
on the antigone so i took this as a sign
you know right i mean antigone so i went
uh and uh it wasn't published i read the
typescript my french was
non-existent but i had i knew the greek
so i kind of
you know worked through this
and um
so that was where
uh how i first started to read la calm
and you know again i've always loved
these really torturously hard reading
processes like greek
and
so you know uh
and i've
and a few of them you know a few of the
canadians are also
um you know really into jazz or or also
playwrights or also direct
opera so there's a kind of eclectic
group
i noticed that sophocles made a very
brief uh
cameo in your film as well
yes yes yeah there are a few there were
a few little
for the theory the theory literate crowd
oh yeah oh yeah i mean
you know like um
corey disc in the production designer
who i'm very did a great job but i was
very particular you know sometimes on a
set they're kind of like hey we need
some books here put some books there i'm
like no no no no
they're not just putting books there you
know we are going to be very careful
about which books are there and you know
uh
so yeah all those choices were
um
i mean they're not uh yeah they're not
like a secret
um
reading but but they were very you know
what black hall was working on at that
time
uh some of the influences
uh
some of my own passions in relation to
uh la calm but yeah all of that was
carefully uh chosen
yeah there are some definite easter eggs
in there both for the the theory
literate crowd and the those
knowledgeable about france um
some of the statues and the opening
shots
can we ask about one in particular
because we were we were wondering about
it why the mao the death of mao
newspaper
oh yeah um well you know it it came up
as a possibility i went oh yeah
oh yeah that's good let's use that you
know it it introduces again death you
know for one thing
um there's a whole there's the theme of
black cause death you know the sense of
i mean i think it's what you know one of
the things a lot of people say is oh
he's so much more sympathetic than
he comes across in the rudinesco
biography
and
you know i there are a number of reasons
for that i think
um you know my own
connection is through uh particularly my
late friend alain dj vile who who uh
was analyzed by la con and as the editor
of uh katya la call which is an
interview with all
these people who were analyzed by that
call
and uh i think had a have a warmer
sense of um
of who that call was you know i think
also you have the voiceovers where you
know i think at one point he says [ __ ]
you know which is
you know that he's he's course correct
you know he you know he really is not
you know he really doesn't know
necessarily you know with all that for
us you know he's not only
uh yeah maybe he's supposed to know but
you know he's kind of
thinking on his feet it's he's very
performative i think
i think one of the things i found really
interesting about it
uh was thinking about
blackcall as a
or an
analysis as a performative act in a way
you know references he makes in passing
to
circus or vaudeville
you know the fact that his uh silviba
thai of course was a great a great
beauty great actress
and
the the presence of death you know his
own mortality
so i think that was one reason
and um
you know mao i think mao is
also
a figure
a political figure a figure of
the communist
tradition
which really reflects that time period
uh certainly a lot of people around
lack call were very interested uh in mao
um
so uh it had a lot of
a lot of uh
echoes to it yeah yeah i i loved that um
sort of parallel struggle in a way some
of the things that lacan seemed to be
going through in the film
paralleled some of the things that serie
aimo was going through right and it
really sort of
it humanizes him in a way which is very
nice because he's such a towering figure
in theory and he seems like he's got all
the answers
but it sort of humanizes them and brings
them down to earth
and uh i really i really enjoyed that
and then the mao reference
really
for me it just yeah it like you're
saying it hooked in these contextual
aspects like i mean the french communist
party was huge
and there are all kinds of divisions you
know or are you uh are you a post
marxist or uh or a maoist or a stalinist
and all those sorts of divides that
really emerged so it nicely like hooked
that stuff in for me
and that's that's sort of what i thought
he was reading the other side he's like
even the heart has a gender and then you
see mao on the other side of the paper
is really it's just one of those things
that your imagination can then sort of
fill in all these all these things in
the film and it's
really great um
but one one thing i also wanted to ask
about too is is um
just as background the idea of filming
it all in in this single room
in this single space
and i i did a little
looking around and saw you mentioned you
have some inspiration
behind dealing with films
as something shot sequentially in a
single space you know over 10 days as
you said um
was it um robert altman is it is an
inspiration for you for that
yes well for shooting and sequence you
know uh
all there are very few filmmakers who
regularly have shot in a sequence
antonioni is one robert altman is
another i have done two films with uh
elliot gould
who worked uh who was
did a lot of really great work with
altman
um and working with elliott
i kind of
uh picked up the ghost of
or or was inspired by the ghost
devolvement in some ways and began
uh
in another really
low budget
film done shot very quickly called
uh fred won't move out began to
which was my first experiment shooting
in sequence and you can really do things
in terms of
you know like playing a piece of music
you you you can really feel the room and
feel how things are going
and and therefore take
chances with the camera and i was
you know also time was so important
because
of course the short sessions
which sarajevo is revolting against or
not short sessions of variable length
sessions uh
um where uh
you know la call like the director is
calling cut in a sense
um
were uh maybe very aware of the sense of
time and then of course
also
that film and psychoanalysis
having a way the same birthday of 1895
um or at least grow up the end of the
19th century that they're both
they're both inventions you know i mean
uh psychoanalysis is in many ways an
invention
and
and so is cinema and i think one of the
things that
uh
um lacan did
was uh in returning to freud he was also
um
you know translating the inventive
spirit of freud you know
uh by levy strauss and so sure and kojov
in so many ways
for all for all that he emphasized the
sense of return one of the things he was
returning to
was a sense of
of invention uh of a certain kind of
being out on the edge of things
in a way
that was
not acceptable to
what the dominant american
form of psychoanalysis that those at
that time
when they dominated the ipa
they dominated
uh as they did many fields at that time
and uh you know he was
pushing back against that
whereas
you know psychoanalysis in the united
states
was
highly medicalized at a time run by the
uh american
american medical association there was a
real effort
to
uh have
have it become a medical profession and
it was kind of like
um
you know it popped it was incredibly uh
successful for a short time
so after the second world war but it's
this really odd form
really odd form to this day uh called
ego psychology
you know i mean it was everywhere it was
incredibly
um
present in in popular culture and then
it just bombed it had very
reactionary ideas about what women
should be doing in the society
about homosexuality
so
in being medicalized
the nightmare that floyd had
uh
worried about in
lay analysis and writing about lay
analysis
that
you know
that that physicians
for them
not in all cases but often their
training is not shakespeare it's not
dante it's not good
you know it's not
uh these things that we're we're we're
in intrinsic to uh freud's formation
um and that you know la call who's of
course drawing on
whether it's the
the antigone or or
or uh martin assad
is very much in touch with
the american translation
uh strakey's
translation kind of emphasized
uh a more medical approach
and and was really trying to
institutionalize
whereas you know la call was
was pushing
you know pushing the envelope in a
certain way
as he was addressing what was really you
know things that were important in
society and which
uh remain
very important today as part of your phd
if i'm not mistaken or your graduate
work at least was you you were
volunteered or worked at an outpatient
facility for the severely mentally ill
and i was wondering if you could discuss
some of those experiences maybe how they
how they influenced you your views on on
mental health on psychology and maybe
how it influenced your filmmaking yeah
um
yeah it really is a period in my life
that uh
was a real catalyst um i mean i often
joke well my first film was about
lobotomy this one's about psychoanalysis
come on there you know
uh but so clearly um
you know these are interests that have
stayed with me
um but i was uh volunteering at an
outpatient center for severely
chronically mentally ill
and
you know basically
if you're in a hospital the state has to
pay for you
if you're homeless
the federal government picks up much
more so this was part of the push for
labon transorbital and then basically
for farm pharmaceuticals originally
starting with thorazine
was to be able to transfer starting with
california under reagan
to transfer the financial burden
of
of mental health care
from
from the states to the federal
government
this was after
uh you know at the end of the second
world war they built these huge
hospitals they thought they were going
to just be
able to put people in for short periods
of time and then
bring them out and that model hadn't
worked so
so
an outpatient center for severely
chronically mentally ill is
uh a rarity and uh
you know it's really fortunate um the
people who are there were
you know they they
from a long shot they weren't in any
sense lucky but given the possibilities
of the um
mental health care in the u.s
which is kind of a
you know there's a narrative that gets
repeated every 60 or 70 years
which is of a horror show
i mean at the end of the second world
war during the second world war there
had been all these conscientious
objectors
uh who were often sent to work in the
psychiatric hospitals
and these were really smart
you know uh people connected
they were
mennonites for example
and
so they they saw this horror show and
they carefully documented it
um you know they took notes
and uh so at the end of the second world
war
um
there's an expose in the new york times
excuse me in life magazine with these
uh brutal photos of the conditions and
psychiatric hospitals
and um and so action is taken
but it's you know again it's it's also
at a moment where
the profession of psychiatry in the u.s
wanted to move out of the hospitals they
wanted to be
like their colleagues who were you know
the new suburbs and they wanted to be
treating
um uh this new uh middle class
and uh so it also served them
um and the model they took was
from
you know wartime in a sense that that
soldiers had gotten better by being true
this was what they said and this gets
reset after the vietnam war after the
war iraq it always gets rediscovered
it's an amazing act of forgetting and
remembering that goes on you know that
war holy [ __ ] we just discovered war
it's incredibly bad
you know
and then they you know send out
young people to one more time be
brutalized in the war and then they go
holy [ __ ]
and uh so there was a brief moment after
the second world war
where
there was a real interest in mental
health care a real earnest interest
and it's the time when the national
institute of mental health is formed
the first mental health act is right
after the second world war
um
so there's this real
engineered or a moment of real uh
consensus around it
but so
this place where i was volunteering i
was i had i was running groups
when where we were reading aloud
uh the short stories of edgar allen poe
hawthorne and melville
um
uh the people in these groups loved it
because um you know usually in these
groups
they would have to kind of
reproduce their illness
um or you know
it was there was a kind of closed
circuit but that so there was a way in
which um
like the voice was an instrument and
they got to play this
these amazing tunes
um so those were those were great and
then there was an alp
there was a
theater program
which at that time was
where they would come up with their own
plays
and the play which i was involved with
they came up with which was called world
13a and it was about a medicine a pill
which could which could cure all mental
illness but had one side effect
it brought back the dead hey
psychoanalysis and i thought oh my god
this is
psychoanalysis you know whatever it was
it was so fascinating and uh
so and that program around the time i
was there was being shut down
and the theater just to show you how
these things the theater
program which was so amazing they
changed it so
um
they made it they said it's much more
useful if of of the clients they were
called clients
uh if the clients had
work uh where the theatrical
uh situations were like they're behind a
cash register at mcdonald's or they're
checking someone's bags gross um you
know something much more
you know whereas what we were doing was
much different than that it really
wasn't at all about adaptation
to
um
whatever you want to call it neo-liberal
economy or
uh you know this this kind of
but so that
you know maybe in some ways for better
but in some ways for worse
was is symptomatic of the way in which
uh programs like that which were being i
mean the program was called continuous
that's the only word i remember
continuous and as somebody said that was
the kiss of death
you know to anyone like you know that
continuous enough get rid of that
program
you know
oh man yeah drugs and lobotomies yeah i
i mean i remember uh learning that the
the inventor of the trans-orbital
lobotomy won a nobel peace prize i think
in like the 50s but of course it was
shocking because i had watched one flew
over the cuckoo's yeah
and sort of seen
i don't know if it was a trans orbital
but the like sort of closing scenes is
just him as a vegetable kind of thing
and it's
it's shocking from today's perspective i
guess that that was considered a a
treatment yeah well you know it was it
was interesting was that the cri it was
really about the criteria you know they
would say
uh
uh this this person this woman
uh complains about doing laundry um she
no longer complains about doing laundry
um or you know often people in
institutional settings
you know who were
a pain in the ass
and then the next day they weren't a
pain in the ass
and so and that was you know that was
the criteria for for improvement
yeah
and then there's this sort of
weird middle ground
between you know
normalizing somebody making them fit
into the already sort of dominant um
beliefs that you have to have to be a
part of society and then there's the
sort of lobotomy or even just sort of
the the bedlam model i guess just take
them out put them aside
out of sight out of mind and then
you know it's like psychoanalysis tries
to adopt a middle ground almost and i
just love the idea you know this
analysis is where you can start to forge
a new path forward
rather than being removed from society
rather than being normalized right
and it also
uh you know it doesn't necessarily
the idea of
it's
not it's not really there it's kind of
you know more of um
seeing symptoms outside of the model of
trying to get back to normal you know
it's more about
i love the moment when david patrick
kelly the actor who plays zlatan very
near the beginning goes you're an
analysis
you know it's like
you know anything is possible
it's a wonderful moment where he seems
like
you know a little
crazy but you know it's kind of
it's it's you know refreshing in a way
that it's uh
um
you know it's about
uh these possibilities that come from
uh this process so
um well
i'm glad you brought oh sorry i'm just
gonna say i'm glad you brought it back
to the film because
we're about halfway done and i want to
make sure we
get to pick your brain about that
specifically
yeah um so i had one question
in that this this film depicts
analysis the process of analysis you
know more or less realistically of
course there's cuts and all that but
more or less realistically except for
one choice you made
that breaks the depiction or disrupts
the depiction which is to give
the viewer access to lacan's thoughts
via
voiceover oh so i thought you were gonna
say the capoeira dance oh yeah
but of course that usually takes place
usually not that early in the analytical
process it but there is
no usually the copper eras
yeah no i'm sorry
i actually i actually forgot about that
scene but anyway i wanted to ask about
the voiceover because lecon occupies
this position of the other for sarayama
but then the viewer gets not only access
to
serie ema's process her working out but
also to lacan's thought and in some
cases his strategy like what he's trying
to get at a first so i was wondering
what you're thinking was behind the use
by giving the audience that kind of
transcendent point of view in that
situation
well
here again i can um
i can uh give credit to and blame
uh betty milan uh who in the stage
version uh
goodbye doctor had these soliloquies
where the characters were turned
and you know
this is one of the places where um
film is so great with voice over which
creates
a voice which has
you know is kind of just floating it's
not
uh situated in any way
um
and so you know i used the voiceover for
these uh these internal voices that
betty
um
had created and that i you know i think
work well there's one you know another
thing about the structure of the film
and what attracted to me
me to it was um the idea that
cerama is the question of childbirth
um
i was thinking of
of uh socrates and this
uh metaphor for analysis that uh la khan
was very fond of of miudix
that uh you know likes socrates says i
you know i have no idea you know i all i
can do is be a midwife and give birth
uh to
um
what's inside you you know this truth
and um so in a way you know sarayama has
to
uh give birth to her own subjectivity
uh before she can give birth to a child
that her symptom
which is as we find out
uh involves
childbirth and and
uh
fantasies around pregnancy
uh
so there was this double level you know
in a way there was both
uh that is a narrative and there was
also that in terms of
the analytical process
uh from uh la carl's perspective
that also you know
uh
interested me because
often these kinds of doubling things you
know are are very
resonant and give you a chance to do
something that otherwise might just slip
away
yeah and um oh go ahead
i
i was just uh just digging a little more
into the film um when you when you
noticed uh or when you when you said
that um
about lacan's influences he was
influenced by sosur and levy strauss and
and obviously that's one of the khan's
twists he puts on psychoanalysis is to
bring semiotics into play and we know
the importance of words and what is
usually called the the signifier right
in lacan and some of these words that
are popping up um
because of the the language conflict
between the brazilian portuguese and the
and the french of lacan
um it it really highlights in a way the
importance of language in the
psychoanalytic process yes and
and i i wanted to know your thoughts on
that and and even how you chose these
words even if that's not giving away too
much like the first one i believe that
pops up is mocktube
meaning fate destiny or literally it is
written some of these words and
eventually obviously the name of the
father kind of becomes another
another point of another lightning rod
for insight and um
yeah how did you work these signifiers
into the uh into the story
i what i can take credit for is
um
doing the film in english which was to
add a third language
you know she's
speaking in brazilian portuguese or no
that's her first language the analysis
is taking place in
french
which for her is a second language and
then this is all represented in english
which is yet a third
language and of course it's the one
for for various reasons
was the was the easiest for me uh it's
the one where
i mean i have done a few things in
french
so
again that kind of highlighted
uh language and yet another way that
you're kind of in a way between
languages
uh rather than in any one language
uh you're you're um
which has a very interesting effect i
mean we all live
uh we may not be aware of it necessarily
but
you know where we all
i mean english is not even the title i
mean one of the things that drew me to
the title i do that cause
you know i picked up a dictionary and
i'm i think
miriam webster and there was a dude i
mean
is a word
in is an english is considered an
english word it's it's um
so this kind of betweenness of languages
um
even within
uh
you know what we sometimes
can reflexively think of as monolithic
you know english or french
or in fact
and some languages are more like this
uh are even more kind of
of uh
made are made up of different rocks
different
different crystals or different things
within them
uh
was i think something that has a very
subtle effect
i can't take credit unfortunately
uh for the choice uh betty is her is
from uh uh lebanon
originally it's it's her own story um of
her own analysis
uh with la con
uh the play
what i took from the novel uh was really
just the introduction that first speech
where she says
uh which i love where she goes look
one thing i'm not going to talk about
because it's not relevant
is immigration and being being an
immigrant i mean it has nothing to do
and of course it's you know everything
but it's uh but i
that was the one
uh
uh
monologue or one
speech in the beginning which comes from
the novel the rest really
um came from from the play and i i
brought it into
because it was
such a key
element
and uh and the re and the kind of
rejection of it was so striking
good i was wondering as well about or
going back to something that pills was
just saying about um the the choice of
the voice over and just generally i
think the film you know it's its ability
to depict um lacanian psychoanalysis you
know as you mentioned the variable
length sessions yes um and all those
different things
i'm wondering um were there certain
aspects in the play or in the novel that
like you either
didn't end up including or and just
broadly i guess the challenge of trying
to capture some of these
um like lacanian idiosyncrasies to like
the analytic process because i know what
pills was asking was about the voiceover
and when he was asking that question i
was sort of thinking well the voiceover
makes it possible to see like the kind
of work that lechon is an analyst is
actually doing because a lot of it is
just him saying go on
speak you know and it's like to someone
who doesn't know much it would seem like
he's not doing much but of course the
goal is to try to get to subjectivize
the unconscious right to get the
conversation to happen between the
analysts and and their own unconscious
and try to not subjectify lacan right
it's trying to get him out of that
position that requires a work that you
probably can't see unless you're in
lacon's mind in a way so that challenge
that was depicted well i thought
so we're seeing on one hand the the
depiction
of a
subjectification the psych by one method
the psychoanalytic method and then that
is also i don't think it's negligible
represented on a screen using richard
your method which is the
film depiction
so you are subjectifying him as he is
trying to subjectify her unconscious yes
yeah yes it was it um you know i think
the camera uh which we you know again we
drew up i had looked at um this
tv series in treatment
and i thought wow boy do i not want to
do that
[Laughter]
you know because the camera was always
level to the ground and it made sense
for that because it was about
two people one person is a professional
who knows certain things the other
person has
issues and they can the professional can
transmit to the other that professional
knowledge
and
that ain't what i was after you know
what i
the model
i found uh was in uh carl dreyer's joan
of r
which you know uses these extreme angles
it's about this woman who's being
you know she's going to be burned at the
stake
um and there's this whole sense of
you know of powerlessness of power of
knowledge
um you know who has knowledge
um and it and it's actually
um
very
it's very dynamic because
at as i looked back at dreyer's film and
i thought about how joan dark in some
ways
is helpless but you know in the camera
but also she has all she's with god you
know i mean so she's also
you know
screw them you know so she's and the
camera so it's not a simple matter of oh
you choose
a high angle to make her look helpless
and then the lowing it's much more of a
dynamic and dramatic process
so you know we also went back and used
valentina kaniglia the cinematographer
whom i've worked with a few times and
did such a great job on this film
we shot four three you know this
aspect ratio that goes back
to the earliest uh cinema and which is
so great for
the individual subject for one you know
for that portrait and black and white
you know which again
uh for this subject matter worked so
well
and i think those kinds of angles
um and being very economical about
choices we made there's one overhead
shot
oh richard richard richard i have to
fanboy here a second because that is
just two great shots in the film and
that is one of them my favorite one
because
well
for the listeners here this is an
auditory medium and i'm trying to
describe a visual depiction but you'll
see where i'm going
um
the screen is looking down on the office
from above and on the bottom half of the
split
there is the two chairs that are facing
each other where they look at each other
and speak and at the top of the split is
the the couch where she lays down and
ultimately he sits behind her
and this split screen is separated by a
white bar that they both cross
they cross from the chairs facing each
other
over to the couch and you know the real
con heads out there you'll know what i'm
saying the split
the bar
halfway through analysis
so this is a conquering
of the physical space
that is crossing the split
in the subject
of the couch they conquer her
subjectivity in this split screen scene
great job great work
yes and then there's the mention of sex
just before that the sex of words
you know that uh
like with french and
portuguese having uh words you know each
word having its sex and the question of
sex
and then you know i was thinking of the
barred subject and this this that line
there that it creates this cut
so they're penetrating this the couch
not just conquering it
bills we'll let you
[Laughter]
the screen
yeah
the the way you use that because it's
such a small space
but it always felt like there was just
more
coming out of it by the angles but also
the focus on the objects in the room
there's there's effigies there's the
books there's the sort of
little i don't know if you call the
partial objects or things she fixates on
everything right then and the board me
and not let's not forget yeah i noticed
that yeah he holds up this like sort of
he just looks like he's untangling wires
or something almost but it's it but then
for a second it's like oh my god that's
the baromian knot that's the real
imaginary symbolic yeah linkage there
and uh david patrick kelly and i
it turned out by chance we both had
studied mind and fears
and we really bonded around that but
and that object i mean he just well he
loved playing that he fell in love with
black comp playing.com um there was
something about david patrick kelly
who's a really interesting
uh
you know human being pro actor really
classically trained
um and for whom
the work of the actor
uh is
uh is a profound
uh uh
thought process
and role in society
um he found playing black khan
absolutely uh mesmerizing
um and the boar of me and not was
something
uh he was became uh
preoccupied with and he chose the moment
of
you know of uh it's the one moment where
you know we have uh lachen's voiceover
but the one moment where he speaks to
himself out loud
is
just
in connection with the bore me and not
you know that
um and he asks a question about
why she's made one choice around money
um and not another um
and i thought it was just you know it
was just spot on
uh
and and worked uh in a way
that um very happy yeah i don't know if
this is just a connection i'm making in
my head um but also the way you use the
space um and you brought up dreyer and i
remember in another in an interview i
saw you you also mentioned paul schrader
and the transcendental style and he
speaks about dreyer to exemplify it yeah
quite a bit but also he's kind of in the
end says maybe brazal does it a bit
better but though the point is
representing the holy other oh there's a
key term eric could you quickly uh let
us know what the transcendental style is
yeah i mean
it's the transcendental style is is a
method of of i guess creating tensions
within the space of the film
and eventually what you want to do is
evoke a sense of the holy other which i
read when i read schrader i read that as
a religious thing but then when i saw
the film and about lacan i'm like oh my
the holy other right right yes the
unconscious and
the angles i thought and the ways you
used the space really just sort of
created those tensions i know it wasn't
like a gothic space it was more of a
human-sized space but it still evoked
that transcendental kind of style for me
and maybe that's just because you
mentioned it and then i went back and
watched the film again and my mind has
started putting those connections in
there valentina and i had that very much
in mind and also you know schroeder
talks about how
most films try to grab you by the throat
and never let go you know they're just
this and then he said this is
transcendental style and i remember
uh he mentions this film by victoria de
sica where there's this poor girl trying
to light a match
and she can't light it and then she
tries again and she can't light it and
she tries again she can't like just
you know hollywood that [ __ ] cut that's
gone
but you know that in this transcendental
style you you hold on things
and suddenly they have a meaning you
know
he says well it's either really boring
and you're really bored
or
you start to lean in instead of
you know instead of this thing that's
constantly trying to overwhelm you with
stimulation
you know you start to
you you realize you have to lean in you
have to be involved with
performance of what's going on
and of course for
you know for uh people interested in
analysis and also i would say critical
theory
they have
by their very nature and affinity
with that kind of process you know that
that the production in a way
um
a certain part of the production is
taking place
during the making of the film but then a
certain amount of the production is
taking place in the reception of the
film
um
and
so leaving room for that you know we
were very
uh conscious of like
uh
you know we were gonna risk
being boring you know we were going to
like
not push not push this
uh in terms of pacing and such to really
kind of
of uh
really be
uh working in a particular in a
particular way and that's why also
filming in sequence you can really much
more
uh
work on that edge i think
yeah and i i really loved the um
i guess in my head i read it almost as
transposing those gothic tensions that
you get from gothic architecture you
know it's like it's really big there's a
lot of downward pressure you need all
kinds of apparatus to sort of diffuse
that
downward force or the whole thing will
collapse and that seemed to me sort of
transposed onto the
i guess the chain of signifiers the um
the sort of thinking that goes on in
sarajevo's head and then her engagements
with the khan like when she sort of
first said
like i'm from lebanon but i don't want
him to know that i want him to think i'm
sort of right daughter of the founder of
brazil
but then and then it's like oh but is he
going to think i'm indian i don't want
him to think that then his first
question of course is or one of them
anyway he says do you have indian blood
in you because and then she goes what
the heck
like those sorts of little like i want
this but i don't want that and then
something else happens i don't want this
but i want that and it this
the tensions seem to be transposed onto
the you know the chain of signifiers the
the the narrative or the the talking
itself seem to capture those sorts of
tensions that schrader describes in
dreyer's
style as well and i i really love that
and speaking of that top-down tension i
think she says at one point explicitly i
don't want the labels i don't want to be
labeled as nothing right which speaks
exactly to that
downward tension that you that you're
kind of yes yes
uh
yeah she's you know uh she's the
protagonist
you know i mean she's the
she's the anna lee sand right i mean
she's the one
and that's what's i think also
uh great about
uh the film or the story
uh you know is that in the end she
uh in the final scene when she walks out
and blackhaw is in a much more
it's almost like he's
uh depleted you know he's he's he's
spent in a certain way um
he reaches out to to get the money
and she just leaves it on the table and
walks out
but um you know she's kind of she pushes
back i mean that was something very
early on that before we started shooting
uh
uh the ishmania mendez the uh actor
actress
uh who plays uh the woman uh who does
the analysis
um
was asking me and spoke to betty you
know can i
you know can i
push back against him and
you know that's a that's one thing uh
where i think you know you're
translating somewhat into contemporary
terms i think
benny was surprised at how much
uh ishmania uh chose to like
uh give him hell or push back a little
bit but i think it's you know again it
it translates well uh in terms of
um
contemporary zeitgeist around uh
gender and
politics but it's uh
but it it it does work very well and uh
yeah she really um
you know she is it's it's her voice
right it's i do like kong is is her
she's the one who says i do that calm
this is maybe a much broader question
and it's okay if you don't feel equipped
to answer it but like sort of just the
discourse of mental health in in north
america and the english it seems like
it's been growing more more acceptance
like destigmatizing it but at the same
time it seems like psychoanalysis is
kind of delegitimized in at least the
anglo-american world
and i find that those two things kind of
happen in parallel and there's sort of a
proliferation of you know ultra i guess
what they call evidence-based
approaches and i wonder if you had
thoughts about like what like how that
and also the interesting thing that in
the latin american world right and in
the in france i'm assuming like these
things are still like at least the
canadian analysis are still pretty
popular so
i don't know if you had thoughts about
that dynamic it's kind of a broad
question well it's the reception of
ideola.com
uh has been really uh great in mexico in
brazil argentina
you know litanian groups that i would
probably never have come into contact
with
were
organized screenings online and then we
have a discussion
and
they're great i mean they're really
so interesting to find
um in
areas of latin america central america
um
people who
are interested in lack call
and
you know
want to
want to to see the film and to discuss
it so that was
incredibly exciting and very interesting
in terms of
you know those countries own
approaches to to
uh
symptoms and and uh mental health care
and
uh
very different than that in the united
states
uh it's certainly the pandemic has
brought about a i would say
proliferation of
of
discourses discussions
around
mental illness
symptoms
at the same time
it's a lot of it seems to be
confined within
a paradigm
uh which is
the dominant paradigm and um you know
it's it's interesting that up to the
second world war you know quantum
physics in terms of the paradigmatic
science
it was really physics and then after the
war it becomes biology
um and um in a way for the canadian
psychoanalysis i think the paradigmatic
science in some ways
is is quantum physics
um and
it's it's it's um
yeah zizak mentions that quite a bit i
think this uh he brings up the quantum
physics example
yeah yeah you know i i was i had done
research the history of psychiatry
section of the pain with me uh which is
the oldest history of psychiatry section
in the u.s used to be in the basement of
the payne whitney
uh which if you were insane and
and anyone important you you went mad
there uh and william burroughs marilyn
monroe
if you became at payne whitney a uh
if you stayed there
they uh you had a silver napkin ring
with your name in graze
elizabeth bishop was there
um they had suicide-proof windows it was
built in the 20s
and it was fondly torn down
in the
90s i filmed it after uh with a little
video camera
after it had been torn down and i was
just
and the people who had been
staying in these rooms started to write
on the walls with magic markers and i
still have that footage but it was
incorporated afterwards it was
incorporated into the hospital in other
words
today if you walk if you go over to the
east side and you
look for the pain whitney it's a branch
within the hospital
and
you know if you look at the history of
mental health care in the u.s
just in new york just in new york city
there's this wandering relationship
between
how close or distant
the
mental health care is from
the physical
treatment of physical illnesses
and
you know there are times when they've
gotten closer or farther away there
um and um
and and now they're really
joined at the hip
um
and
you know i think there are
you know i'm not a clinician and i and i
don't
pretend to be one and and uh you know i
don't
uh i don't
uh i can't provide that but certainly
there are real
pro
problems and challenges
to that to that paradigm
and
i think there's a lot of
possibilities um
offered by the uh the alternative
paradigm that i think psychoanalysis and
particularly
lacanian psychoanalysis
offers
both either directly or through its
influence on more traditional
treatment modalities yeah i remember one
time i was sitting in the backyard of my
friend and his dad who we have a very
good conversational uh relationship he
started talking to me after a few beers
about sort of like anxiety and it was so
striking to me like his anxiety and it
was so striking how he was talking about
it in purely scientific terms about like
brain chemistry
they discovered that there was like this
chemical imbalance and it's like he
totally wanted to
you know create this this objective
barrier between him and and i was so
curious i like i pushed i prodded a
little bit but he was very resistant to
want to talk about it in any other terms
um
well you know it's the uh the
the tagline for the film is uh or the
log line attack attack
is um you know
the passion for ignorance
um you know it's the worst passion of
all or
but people often really don't want to
know
yeah
yeah yeah i love that and i think one of
the lines in the film that works against
that sort of um
also interpretation that victor was just
discussing is that if we're you know if
if we forget the past and we're going to
become a victim of it and to sort of
repeat it over and over again and
and the effort to bring back the
memories that have been repressed
is part of the point of the process not
simply you know treating it with drugs
which have their place maybe here and
there right but in the end it's about
it's about
not just the words you're using which
are the important clue
but also
leading this the and alice and to bring
back the memories that matter because
then to another quote life depends on
what we can say and i guess you'd say
you know
being out of sorts depends on what we
can't let ourselves say right sir right
right you mentioned earlier uh
richard about um in treatment which i
remember kind of enjoying that show it
came out a while ago i did too
no no i wasn't interpreting you as
necessarily um uh knocking it just i
know you were talking about the cinema
took cinematography style right um yeah
not but i'm cut but that made me just
think thinking about that like of the
depictions in film of therapy
i was just kind of curious if you had
like any favorite depictions aside from
your own depiction of therapy and film
you know there's the sopranos obviously
that has that famous oh yeah and then
and then uh yeah and then obviously like
cronenberg did that film on freud which
only showed analysis like very briefly
so
they tend to you know films and analysis
tend not to show analysis yeah it's
unfortunate it's very interesting even
like shock corridor
uh where they okay we have to go to
treatment give her a couple objections
you know because they
you know they they're they're the issue
of time
um and even
um
you know john houston who did
uh this film that i was very interested
in for it was the last of three films he
did
for the uh war effort during world war
ii was called let there be light and it
was about
returning soldiers who have um these
post what we now would call
post-traumatic
stress disorder and they're uh they go
to this hospital in a hospital setting
and they're treated with a kind of
uh mcdonald's form of psychoanalysis
using these these drugs that supposedly
speed it up
but he thought he had made these this
film which was
highly patriotic but they
uh it was the night it was supposed to
be released or premiered at moma
military police grabbed it and it wasn't
released for another 30 years wow at
which point when it was finally released
people thought you know what what's the
big deal it's nothing so
you know oh about this film but i think
in a way you know again it was at a time
when they finally decided boy this makes
war look bad
you know
uh because these guys are really messed
up you know it really has not been uh
kind kind to them
um and i think it was just there was
there was a shift there was a little
slight window
after the second world war
when there was an openness about what
had what had happened and then it just
closed
close shut really quick and i think the
film bridged it but but that gave him
the motivation
to do um
a film with montgomery clift which had
various different titles including a
secret passion
where montgomery cliff plays sigmund
freud
on a um on a script that was originally
written by john paul
and then
you know went through all kinds of
rewrites and everything
and it's still you know but again it's
about the discovery of psychoanalysis
and the minute they discover
psychoanalysis the film's over i mean
they
they really that you know and it's not
by chance you know i mean
i don't i i can't remember how many
times i've walked into major museums
with shows on the surrealist and they
talk about the surrealists were very
interested in the subconscious no they
weren't interested in the subconscious
you know and
it's really striking uh when these major
institutions
um
start talking about
uh you know somehow uh a face of the
unconscious
um
so it's it's curious there uh there are
a few
examples like that um
but i'm probably you know repressing the
bio i can't you know i can only think of
my own
fair enough
i would i would love to know um i don't
know as as we wrap up um
richard leeds what's uh what's next for
you what's what is the next project
you'll be working on
v13
v13 uh is based on
a a play called vienna 1913
uh
which is about
uh two young men
who become friends one
is
uh living
in the park
he's uh homeless he loves animals
artists vegetarian
adolf
and then the other young man is sent to
freud to do an analysis
and his symptom
of which he's very embarrassed because
he knows better
is that he feels an instinctive
revulsion tinged with hatred for jews
and it's about the rise of anti-semitism
in vienna
before the first world war
um
and
uh it was written by uh
uh alain dj bio um my late friend
and i've been working on it for years
and years and years and it pre-dates by
you know a decade
uh
i do like home
and uh and
in a way it's part of what
drew me to ideal back home
um
and now finally i'm making it i'm
shooting it by we're shooting it in new
york uh we're
kind of like like a like a modern dress
shakespeare we're shooting
uh new york today for vienna
uh before the first world war
um with some interesting echoes around
uh you know
some of uh
the rise of fascism
etc
so i'm just beginning to cast that i
wish i could share
with you uh some of the but i can't
uh but you know we're we're
um
we're working on that and uh we'll begin
filming that in october
nice all right awesome that sounds
exciting that's excellent um one final
question very quickly if people have
been uh listening to this i mentioned at
the very beginning of the episode that
this is available you can rent it
through amazon app
and the apple app i was wondering if
those are that's right or how are you
sending people to be able to watch this
right if they're overseas they should go
to uh my
website
richardleads.com that's r i c h a r d l
e d e s dot com
and for that film and for the other
films as well we have links the reason
that's important is because
amazon
and
uh
apple are only for english-speaking
countries
and a lot of the interest in the film uh
is from overseas
and uh
so
the film is available uh through a
platform called aventive
if you're in uh for example mexico or
or france or argentina so um
for those those listeners that's where
they can they can find a link that they
can
by which they can view the film so if
you no matter where you are if you go to
your website you can find something that
fits or that works for you
that's right okay i will put that in the
show notes
uh richards.com
uh thank you so much for uh coming and
hanging out with us we had a great time
this was a little bit outside of our
normal capacity
but i think uh all of us enjoyed it
looking at eric's eric's smiling face
through this this is a great treat yeah
it was
for me as well for me as well i'm very
uh you know again you're
i'm very grateful to have this
discussion
all right how are we
thank you listeners if you have made it
all the way to the end uh this has been
what are we on 91 91 or so
and uh thank you richard and
we'll see you next week
[Music]